have you heard of this thing called
live golf i think it's called live i
don't know how you pronounce it liv nah
what's live golf
live golf okay so
you know about the pga tour it's like
the the main yeah like the nfl tennis
club right
no the gulf
so
so live golf is a competitor to the pga
that just imagines the saudi arabia
effect
exactly a saudi-backed rival
and these guys are basically trying to
it's like they're trying to spin up a
new league by brute force they're
investing hundreds of millions
i think they pledged
yeah me too big big swing so this is not
this is the opposite of sps right so
this is uh bde yeah so so basically they
they put the saudi public investment
fund put in they pledge 400 million
dollars to start the league i think
they've even committed more than that i
thought they offered tiger woods like
500 million or something crazy
news came out yeah they offered him 800
million dollars and he said no
which is like just kind of an insane
thing so but they have signed other huge
stars so phil mickelson uh you know
dustin johnson this guy you know brooks
kefka or whatever who who recently won
the the he won like four majors or
whatever
um cameron smith who's like this is a
young star he signed a 100 million
dollar deal dustin johnson 125 million
dollar deal phil mickelson 200 million
deal they offered tiger and didn't get
him yet
[Music]
all right what's going on dude um
how are you
fantastic so
i have something that i've been thinking
about that i've been wanting to talk to
you about i started um have you ever
seen
that video of adolf hitler at the birth
uh the german olympics in 1936 when he's
watching the olympics and he's like
rocking back and forth have you ever
seen that
bro you can't be blonde haired blue eyed
and coming on here starting off saying
have you ever seen my favorite video of
hitler no no no have you ever seen that
video up the charts bro we're trying to
go up
have you ever seen that video of him
like so he's like basically he there's
this video that i saw a couple of weeks
ago where he's at the olympics and he's
rocking back and forth and he's very
clearly on drugs like some type of coke
or something like he's on drugs and i
started getting curious about it and i
started looking into this and someone in
the comments said that there's this
really good book called blitz so i
bought it it's right here it's called
blitz and basically it's a it's called
blitz drugs in the third reich so
basically
uh after reading it
hitler and a ton of the nazis as well as
just a ton of germany starting in the
1930s like
morphine
heroin and meth was invented and they
used to think that it was like a miracle
drug doctors were like take this meth it
makes you feel great um it's like this
it's like a it's like a it's like a
miracle drug like you get euphoria you
want to stay up all the time you'll eat
less it's this wonderful drug and like
it was a legal drug that bear you know
b-a-y-e-r the drug company now they were
like selling this [__] and they would
even put it in chocolates and there was
like a chocolate that you would eat that
had a little meth in it and it was like
always satisfied or something like that
and like it was so common
and turns out
hitler was a junkie he was getting
injected with meth uh for years and
that's one of the reasons why you know
like when they were getting bombed the
very last minute he was like oh no we're
doing great because he had like these
like you know he was like hallucinating
you know he had like thoughts of
grandeur typical meth [__]
and i started thinking about this
what other stuff in history was supposed
to be one way and be happening like one
time but turns out it was for a totally
other reason and i started looking into
it so for example henry viii he was the
k have you know what protestants are
no
i've heard that word a thousand times i
knew
no
so like there's like the catholics and
then there's the uh the protestants it's
basically like if you're like an
evangelical christian if you're a
baptist if you're like all these other
different types of christian religions
you're probably a protestants maybe by
definition you are anyway someone came
up with it like martin luther came up
with it and and and in the 1500s the
king of england he basically like had
like eight divorces because he couldn't
have a kid like it was it was him he was
infertile and the pope was like hey you
can't have these divorces anymore this
is [__] and he's like nah [__] that
then we're gonna switch to protestant
cause that allows like you know me to
get a divorce and i can have all these
kids and so now like there's a billion
protestants in the world because he just
turns out like won a divorce and then
like there's this like there's this like
story that you're you never know how
barcelona people say barcelona really
funny like barcelona
yeah there's like this urban myth that
the uh king of spain had a lisp
and someone's like hey you know it's
pronounced barcelona and he goes no from
now on it's barcelona because you know
that's just how i say it that's just
my first million yeah
yeah it's like you know mike tyson ruled
the world
uh
i was thinking about like what other
stuff
did we think that was gonna be like you
know was for this like grand reason but
it was really just like you know like
the guy's dad said something like like
george bush invading like you know
looking for weapons of mass destruction
because like his dad was like you know
you're not strong like your brother and
like he or you know
because he couldn't find the remote one
time yeah
oh he had this like leftover like
mission accomplished banner he's like
well we gotta do something with it you
know like what else like what else in
history has been done just for like
totally the opposite reason
i don't know but i bet there's so much
like i think about this with food all
the time when i see oh you know
you know people are like oh you know
that the active ingredient in advil or
aspirin comes from this like oak tree
and like blah blah i'm like
yeah how did we figure that out like who
was just gnawing on trees and was like
you know this one i had a headache
earlier and now i don't have it anymore
right like
all foods was like oh this one kills you
this one's good for you it's like uh
okay but like you know who were the
testers who was figuring this out along
the way i actually think that that was
probably
like what's the most fun time to be
alive was then when nothing when no one
knew anything about anything like you
didn't know what was food and what was
not food like how much just random soil
has been eaten by somebody being like
this has to be food and then somebody
else is like you know sees a chicken
running by he's like no i think under
that feather under those feathers
there's something there there dude
there's all types of good stories like
that and i never research it so like
have you heard about like the invention
of lsd
no the guy uh
he was a european doctor he was trying
to like a doctor right yeah he was just
trying to make like uh i forget what it
was but some type of antibiotic like
just something normal and he got a
little bit of the [__] in his skin like
he like touched it funny and he was like
oh my god this is awesome and then he
like starts tinkering with it even more
and he goes all right let's try this and
he gives himself a huge dose and he
starts running home on his bicycle he's
like nothing's happening like this
didn't work and then all of a sudden
hits him and he like has the biggest
trip of his life and then you like you
know it changes everything
yeah i feel like penicillin there's a
whole bunch of drugs that were
discovered by
by accident for sure um
yeah it's it's i mean i don't know where
you want to go with this topic but i
don't want to go anywhere i just thought
it was interesting this book like i just
been reading this book about drugs and
like the nazis and i was like it's crazy
like the book says that they at the time
in the 30s and 40s when world war ii was
happening that something like 60
of german doctors were addicted to
morphine and they are the ones like you
know voting on what the laws were going
to be around you know how these
controlled substances are handled it's
it's crazy it it changed my perspective
i guess didn't change my perspective but
you know what i mean it's just like a an
interesting read
let me tell you an interesting story
have you heard about this math teacher
in florida
no
these stories can go one of two ways
yeah
yeah yeah
dog the body hunter i'm not i mean this
could go a bunch of different ways yeah
is there a funny like viral video of him
in a 7-eleven
no so get this so uh
so brandon was telling me about this
this is kind of amazing so there's this
guy okay so you know like
um
you know there's like kind of like
school competitions whether it's
spelling bee or math competitions or
whatever so there's this math
competition
and there's this kind of strange thing
going on where one small schools not a
private school
has won like 15 out of the last 17 of
these math competitions and people were
like god what is going on at like
buckholes high school
and the story is kind of amazing so
there's this guy will fraser he's a
he starts as a banker on wall street
and he's doing like bond trading or
something like that and the guys you
know this is like in the 80s he's like
you know this is the heyday of
of where you know
you've ever read those books like liars
poker and things like that it's like the
heyday of wall street people making tons
of money um he retires by 27. so he's
made a bunch of money he's like dude
this is too stressful of a lifestyle how
much should he make i don't want to do
this anymore
i don't know exactly how much he made
but enough to retire at 27. so let's
assume it's you know like i would say 10
million at least okay that's my guess so
he buys a ferrari he drives down to
florida he's like just dreaming of like
a slower calmer life he's like you know
what i'm just going to go to florida
bought this ferrari i'm going to just
play a bunch of golf play a bunch of
basketball and i'm just going to hang
out do ferrari he does that yeah
for a decade
he's you know
that guy you see on like tuesday at 1
p.m just like hanging out at the park
and you're just like how do you know you
don't have a job like what's going on
he's that guy he does it for 10 years no
income 10 years he's just chilling
and he plays a bunch of golf and along
the way he's sort of like yeah you know
what like i'm feeling a little
aimless don't have a great purpose in my
life at this point so he's like he
reaches out to a local high school and
he's like hey um
can i teach golf over there they're like
ah sure he comes over and teaches golf
he was like i like teaching actually
even on wall street i actually i i liked
teaching the young guys so he's like um
what else can i teach like a finance
class you know i'm a former wall street
guy made it big retired kept teaching
finding like no we don't have finance
but uh you can become a math teacher if
you want
and he's like all right i'll do it and
so he goes and becomes a math teacher
and he walks in on day one and he's like
listen let me tell you this right now i
don't need this job yes you guys give me
any [__] this will be my last day and
they're like okay
uh you don't respect and so he
gets one day he's like checking his
mailbox as a teacher and he sees this
math competition coming up he's like oh
like that's cool let's try this
so he enters into the math competition
they go there and they get smoked they
get fifth out of sixth uh place so this
is the second to last
and um and he's like dude i couldn't
even solve some of these problems like
this was hard
but like
the flip you know the switch got flipped
the competitive switch in him gets
flipped and he's just like
actually i liked that competition i
missed the competition of wall street
where it was just like completely doggy
dog and you were like high intensity and
so he decides
to do it again
and again and again and he beca and he
he goes and they get fifth the next time
then they get third and so on and so
forth and he
basically decides that we are going to
dominate these competitions and that's
exactly what's happening dude isn't that
now that's what we're like 15 out of 17.
the 15 isn't that the best when someone
just like sees like a small opportunity
and they're like no one takes this as
seriously as we're going to take this
let's do it you know what i mean i love
it that's exactly what just like that
cheerleading movie that we watched uh on
netflix that it's like they just like it
yeah they take it to the the highest
discovered yeah the one that you made
popular
so the so the guys so people are like
dude what's your secret what are you
doing differently blah blah he's like oh
i just took a different level of
intensity he's like it's just insane
hard work he goes you know um average
math teacher gets 72 hours of classroom
time with their students per semester
um and then they hope that after school
some of those kids come and they learn
for an hour uh you know once a week or
whatever that's what they're putting in
he goes oh i just switched it first i
took all the good math kids i put them
in the same class kind of like almost
like you know like blended of age but
like he's like i put all the best people
in the same class that they would
compete with each other then we used our
class time to start preparing for these
competitions
then i started creating summer camps
where we could get 80 hours in four
weeks so the equivalent of a full
semester of teaching in this high
intensity thing is like and i just
developed a program because they're like
are you the best at math he's like no i
don't even teach the advanced math stuff
like one of my former students teaches
like the hard stuff i just build the
program he's like i put the high school
students with the middle school students
um and that because the middle school
students sort of idolize the high
schoolers they teach down and then the
the middle schoolers rise up it's like
so i built this program where one alumni
basically like the older kids teach the
younger kids the younger teachers get to
even teach the even younger kids
and we just put in way more time he's
like then i started scouting like this
is like you know alabama football so
he'll go and he'll look at the scores of
other schools and he'll find the
high-performing kids and he'll recruit
them to his program and then the
reputation got built where they started
winning so now parents are coming
inbound and being like please take my
kid
and he's like we only have so many spots
i'm sorry and so he's built this like
talent pipeline and not only that they
actually the town pipeline goes even
further now companies like mckenzie and
the big banks wall street they come
recruit from his high school the big
schools ivy leagues for interns
from his high school because they want
his students now so he built like a a
platform for where they can go which
helps them recruit even better students
and so where did you see this
what's that where'd you read this it's
just like
the i think that so it's been in just
like the local florida news for a while
and then i saw something and but what
were you doing right
article who's brandon no he sent this
article from the wall street journal or
something it was like paywall so i only
got the first paragraph i'm too cheap to
pay for it but i was like oh what's the
story and then i found all these local
florida papers that had the the rest
and so um they said like during kovid
they were like oh you got to teach
remotely and he's just like
oh okay yeah we're gonna downgrade the
intensity he's like hell no i resign and
then he went to a church rented out the
church i was like hey if you guys want
to come and train here we could do this
and 140 kids went and trained daily in
his church during coven when everybody
else was lo had to lower their intensity
he ratcheted how old is this guy now
so now he's like in his 60s and so he's
been doing this now for like you know a
number of years so he was basically 27
he took 10 years off so he's closer to
40 10 11 years off and then basically
from 40 to 60 he's just been dominating
this one thing uh isn't this incredible
that's incredible this is incredible i
think there's a few things one just the
intensity number two i think sometimes
if you pick like a lot of people
including me we want to move to san
francisco new york la and try to become
like a medium-sized fish in a big pond i
think there's so much to be said about
being the best or a big fish in a little
pond and like you can make a name for
yourself and have a way better life like
this random dude is having so much more
impact by creating a map being like the
guy for like this very small math
contest versus
you know a rich he's probably way more
fulfilled than being just like another
100 million dollar banker
dude i i want to get diagnosed with a
bad case of sps
i want small pawn syndrome
like i i am a huge believer in this dude
when i so i lived in houston uh in high
school and houston uh i went to a big
public school 5 000 kids
and kids from all over houston and
basically
um
i my life was basketball i loved
basketball
and i remember a game in ninth grade
um the varsity coach i was on the ninth
grade team and i you know the goal would
be to someday be on varsity the varsity
coach
watching her game
and for some reason i think i scored
like two i had like two threes to start
the game
and then all of a sudden the most
athletic kid on their team decided like
nah this guy's not gonna like see the
hoop again and he starts picking me up
full court basically like from the
moment i can move this guy's like in my
shirt
and um you know and i i ca i literally
can't get by this guy like i'm trying to
go left i'm trying to go right i cannot
get by this guy and i don't know what to
do and i'm just basically like getting
frazzled so coach calls time out the the
coachella's timeout the varsity coach
walks under the huddle and i think he's
going to give me this like epic advice
maybe like that varsity advice how am i
supposed to get by this guy and he just
goes you will never play varsity back oh
my god
thanks coach hollingsworth and he's just
like if you can't handle this guy you
will never like he's because he's like i
thought you might be and now i see no as
like some motivational thing then he
just gave you a wedgie and walked away
[Laughter]
is there a checkbox for
faculty but but he was right and in in
the houston pond i was nowhere near
athletic enough to be whatever now
luckily my parents uh my dad gets a job
in beijing we moved to china in the 10th
grade
i go to china first day i started
playing basketball
you know that's for autism these kids
don't get protein over there yeah they
just don't get protein everybody's
scrawny
i'm blowing by everybody
varsity coach walks over he's just like
hey what's your name uh i end up being
captain of the varsity team you know i
got a girlfriend like my life changed
for the better like everything got
better because
i caught sps
i got small small pawn syndrome and i
was able to go be a varsity player over
there captain of the team the captain of
the of a football key of a football team
in rural alabama with 100 students they
live the life screw the big city live
that life you know what i'm saying
and there was a part of me a foggy part
of my memory that remembered like you
ain't [__]
do the man squash that down it got
washed away yeah it quickly got washed
away and like i forgot
it became like you're the [__] you're
the [__] you're the [__] and that's what
you want to do in life uh this guy this
guy's doing it right i actually have
this dream too i was like i just kind of
want to retire and coach high school
basketball like i think that would just
be a lot of fun
and um
and yeah you know this small pawn thing
i think we're onto something i i've
thought about this for a long time i
thought about moving back to st louis
for a minute but my wife wasn't down but
i was like dude i could just be the man
here uh you know i could buy a million
dollar house and it would make the news
you know what i'm saying right a million
dollars in san francisco or new york is
a studio
but i was like it would be it would be
one of the biggest purchases of the
quarter i would make the news it would
be awesome but then i realized i
you know
i don't want to do that
i have straight fire today if you want
uh if you want more all right i've got
fire too i think did you see what i have
in there
uh no i don't have the thing open oh
well
[__] um well you could screw give me one
well okay so
i spoke to like
a bunch of different companies this week
and
they gave me all their revenue all their
profit
and a few of them are interesting and i
could just like bullet point and quickly
go through a few of them you want to do
that
by the way explain why does somebody
yeah why does somebody just give you all
their revenue and give you all their
profit as you say
because it sounds like a unrealistic and
b
like you sort of like tricked them but
that's not the case no i said it's
actually okay so um i've got this like
uh community that i'm running that i'm
not gonna talk about yet but it's like a
ceo community and when they join they
tell me all types of interesting
information so we can place them in the
right group and i messaged eight of them
and i said hey can i talk about you on
the pod and can you answer these
questions and am i allowed to reveal all
of your information well
if i am i allowed to reveal the
information that you gave me and they
said yeah sure so that's how i got it so
nothing like crazy
um which one you want to do all right i
got a couple of them actually
give me the most interesting one first
let's do
uh okay well here's one that's actually
not i don't even think i put it on here
but have you ever seen those pedal
taverns in um like nashville and denver
it's like the bars that you like pedal
with like a they're honestly pretty
obnoxious but you know what i'm talking
about no pedal whatever it's called
i guess you don't like leave the suburbs
of san francisco but in a lot of other
cities denver austin nashville like
these like style cities there's these
things called petal taverns they kind of
look like um
imagine a bar in the middle and there's
eight people sitting on one side and
eight people sit on the other side now
imagine that being on top of a
four-wheeled platform and you're
pedaling that platform while you're
drinking booze you've never heard of
that but you're outdoors right outdoors
on the street
yeah yeah so yeah it's like a some party
thing yeah the guy who created one of
the first ones is in the group and his
name is pete and his business does he
bootstrapped it from nothing just out of
school
it's getting close to eight million a
year in revenue and just the pedal
taverns do about five million a year in
sales
quite profitable and they're using the
profits to buy
the real estate that their pedal taverns
stay in overnight that's a pretty
interesting business
um let's see another one is uh have you
heard of um
let's find another one have you heard of
uh you probably never heard of this so
here's an interesting one there's this
business called the peak it's ran by
this guy named brett so it's a daily
newsletter so just like the hustle
morning brew whatever
mostly bootstrapped only and it's in
canada and so every day it gives you the
news you need to know about canada
canadian news uh only a team of 10
90 000 news newsletter subscribers not
that much and doing about 3 million in
revenue with 30 with a million in profit
pretty good business a small team of 10
90 000 subscribers 53 open rate 67 000
monthly podcast listeners the guys were
like kind of good
uh writers but not really that good and
they just started like
writing and cold emailing people and
hiring writers and after two or three
years it's already about two or three
million in revenue
so what are they doing differently
because that's more revenue per
subscriber than most i think
so right
yeah it's pretty good but basically he
they just said that uh
um
with in canada like there's not that
many there's not as many publications
and b2b advertisers soft software
companies they don't have that many
money places to advertise and so these
guys have just done a really good job of
getting the banks the telecommunication
companies um b2b software companies all
these like high-end enterprise companies
to advertise with them
gotcha that's pretty good um
okay uh we'll do one more i want to tell
you about a company oh fine you can go
okay
okay i want to tell you about a company
that you may have heard of
have you heard of this thing called
live golf i think it's called live i
don't know how you pronounce it liv
or live
wait liv
yeah just live nah what's live golf
live golf okay so
you know about the pga tour it's like
the the main it's like the nfl
right
no
golf
so
so live golf is a competitor to the pga
that just imagines the saudi arabia
effect
exactly it's a saudi-backed rival
and these guys are basically trying to
it's like they're trying to spin up a
new league by brute force they're
investing hundreds of millions
i think they pledged
yeah me too big big swing so this is not
this is the opposite of sps right so
this is uh bde yeah so so basically they
they put the saudi public investment
fund put in they pledge 400 million
dollars to start the league i think
they've even committed more than that i
thought they offered tiger woods like
500 million or something crazy
news came out yeah they offered him 800
million dollars and he said no
which is like just kind of an insane
thing so but they have signed other huge
stars so phil mickelson uh you know
dustin johnson this guy you know brooks
kefka or whatever who who recently won
the the he won like four majors or
whatever
um cameron smith who's like this is a
young star he signed a 100 million
dollar deal dustin johnson 125 million
dollar deal phil mickelson 200 million
dollar deal they offered tiger and
didn't get him yet
but um and phil can only be on it can
only be on live and not pga
exactly so it's a competitive thing so
pga is like there's like i don't know uh
60 events a year or whatever and then
there's like four majors what these guys
are doing is like there's eight events
and they all matter they're going for
more of like the nfl model uh versus
baseball right baseball has 100 you know
almost 200 games a year and you know
they don't really matter but there's
sort of always something on whereas the
nfl is like there's like 17 sundays or
18 sundays and like each one is gonna
matter so that's what these guys are
trying to do with the golf model um and
to like put this into context you know
tiger woods
has earned 121 million dollars in all of
his pga winnings like over time you know
obviously he makes more through sponsors
and and you know um other sort of like
paid events and things like that but
just from the pga his lifetime i think
earnings are 121 million so
liv is coming out strong and basically
giving these guys like
tiger woods lifetime money as a
guaranteed contract instead of the way
the pga works is it's like
there's a prize pool for every
tournament there's nine million for
every tournament the winner gets three
everybody else gets like a piece
depending on how you finished and they
just do that over and over and over
again and so they do 48 events a year
and um and and so live comes in and they
basically are giving guaranteed money
away instead of saying you have to win
in order to be there
and so pga makes like a billion and a
half dollars yeah i'm looking right now
revenue 1.5 a little bit over 1.5
and you know 85 percent of that is like
their their tournaments and the media
rights and ads and all that stuff that
comes from that they have like a nine
year car they're in year one of a nine
year contract and then mr still your
girl comes in and is starting to just
take these stars away
and uh and basically is trying to you
know compete with them they also have
like prize prize money as well and so
they need you know they would need to
generate like a billion dollars as well
to sort of like have like a similar
economics but what's the play here is do
like middle easterns watch a lot of golf
is that the stick is like this no i i i
don't know if that's why like maybe uh
like you know there's like that weird
thing where like
russia
really loves like women's basketball i
don't know if you know that no like if
you're a great women's basketball player
you play college in the united states
then you try to make it to the wnba and
the wnba pays you basically nothing like
you know you'll make like 70 80k yeah
like a shoe salesman salary and then
you'll get like 300 400k for playing the
off season in russia yeah and everyone's
like why does russia care this much
about women's basketball like nobody
asks questions and like yeah it's a
little bit whatever i don't know exactly
what's going on there but
um
but that's like you know they
disproportionately like that sport and
so maybe there is something in saudi
arabia for this or it's just they have a
huge amount of money and they see the
business opportunity where pga basically
had a monopoly on this and if you can
create a successful sports league
these are worth billions and billions of
dollars like we both love the ufc ufc
sold for i think 4.2 billion dollars
um which in my opinion is under now like
very low undervalued for where it is and
that's like the oc is like fringe
compared to nba nfl like these major
major uh major leagues what's more
popular
golf or p or or ufc golf right
i think golf is not more popular but it
generates more revenue but what's more
lame because it's like sort of the
wealth
who beats up who are with their club or
ufc fighter with his hands
i i [__] hate golf i hate golf i can
understand golf golf's out of sport
golf's activity
honestly
how much of
your thinking at the end of the day
boils down to who could beat up who
most
most i think that i think because that's
like
that's like something that we're all
like uh
like we're all afraid of like the guy
who at the end of the day is like oh i
can kill anyone in this room with my
bare hands he is uh you know he's the
true the true dog you know
he has nothing to fear
somebody said this once i was reading
like a nfl scouting report like there
was a draft there's four quarterbacks
they're all like top prospects it's like
who's gonna go number one who's number
two and the guy who does like the draft
he said this line that i thought was so
badass he goes
if they were all on vacation and going
for a you know they they're walking out
to go to the car
they would all throw the keys to mark
like they would check the keys to park
mark's driving and it was like this like
alpha male thing and i was just like
what was this analogy and why did i love
it so much like
if you just said if it was like hey elon
jeff bezos mark zuckerberg bill gates go
out to dinner uh who's paying who's
picking up the chat yeah yeah yeah
who ordered the uber yeah
none of these guys are driving do you uh
when you're in a room like at a
restaurant who sits aisle how how what
percentage of the time when you're at a
restaurant do you look around and be
like whose ass can i kick and who's can
i not
zero really
but i know that you do which is why i
asked you this question because it's
hilarious think about that
zero zero percent of the time dude
i cannot stand golf any sport that you
wear khaki pants to to like play it's
not a sport
that's not a sport it's an activity it's
a hobby it's checkers but it's not you
know
like it's barely a job if you have to
wear cats it's barely a job
like a sport
sport is out of the question
khaki's in a collared shirt
that is not that's i mean that's not a
sport like you you don't sweat it's an
activity it's a hobby
uh this is amazing though i i i don't
like let's get rid of the saudi arabia
thing
uh i think it's pretty cool but if
you're phil mickelson and you have [__]
you money hardcore
and saudi arabia who has you know a lot
of human rights issues offers you this
what do you do do you take it or not
so you double your net worth probably if
you're him
so i think you can't take it alone in a
vacuum because you're not trying to go
sit on an island
doing nothing uh by yourself and like
lose all your relevance you lose your
future earnings if you do that but you
what i do is i say to them look
i'm in if you can go get 40
of this list
to join and you could tell them
that fills in if you're in
and i would basically say you need to
sweep
th a critical mass of us so that this is
relevant that this is considered the top
class i'm not gonna go play in the b
league or the d league uh by doing this
and i would tell them that and i would
say i'll do it you're gonna have to cut
the fattest check of your life and you
got to go get 40 of this list so there's
a fact there's a price that you would
take for sure
oh of course of course if you know if
somebody said hey
you got to go to this podcast on on
android and i'd be like android even is
there a podcast player on google and
they'd be like yeah yeah it's we're
putting a lot of investment into it i'd
be like
all right
all right i'll do that
i'll take this podcast to soundcloud
i'll take it to the google play store
but i'm gonna need to
see seven and a half million dollars
that's what i would say about this
podcast i would i would move this
podcast for seven and a half million
dollars that is my price there's a price
to paid to be a [__] i'm down but uh
so we actually were going to do this so
at one point in time i had a startup
that was based on
uh like streaming uh video games
and twitch was the like 900 pound
gorilla in the room that was like it was
the big streaming platform and we were
just like
we were trying to build a tool that
worked on top of twitch like streamers
could use it when they use twitch
and it was working and every day we'd
come into work we'd work really hard on
this tool but like there was definitely
a part of us that was like dude how did
we end up here we're making this like
tool for twitch streamers
that like is free and then we're hoping
that we can like after they all use it
then we might be able to monetize this
other way we're just like this guppy in
this like
in the in the in the ecosystem of this
food chain we're like that little fish
that like swims in front of the whale's
nose like whatever that thing is called
like we're that and i was like i like
defer con i was like man
don't you just want to be the whale and
he's like i just so badly want to be the
whale and i'm like yeah so what could we
do he's and we're just like mate we went
to the room which white board are like
how would you like compete with twitch
itself how would you just beat twitch
and i was like dude look at the numbers
so we like ran the numbers we're like
twitch has this insane power law where
you can see that
the top you know x 100 streamers if you
take the top 300 streamers they
basically make up all the viewership all
the all the meaningful viewership like
you know i don't remember what the exact
ratios were at the time but like any
power law it's like you know the top one
percent or whatever make up a very
significant portion right viewership so
let's just make up some numbers let's
say the top 300 made up 50 of the
viewers at any given time
i was like so twitch is worth twitch
sold for a billion dollars like a decade
ago or whatever you know seven years ago
it's probably worth five seven billion
dollars now you're saying
that if we could take you know
half of that half if we can get to a
quarter of that we'd be worth a bill you
know we might we might have the
equivalent uh 25 of the traffic would be
worth you know a quarter of what they're
worth which is like a billion dollars
today how much money would it take for
us to throw at those people
right go get 25 of that through top 300
how much money would it take for us to
go through with them to be like come
join our new thing
and we like game theory the whole thing
out we're like all right this guy makes
this much today we basically need to
offer him like 10 times what he's making
today
how much do do some of these guys make
just on twitch so shortly after that the
contracts exploded
but like at that time
the top guys were making like single
digit millions uh per year off twitch so
like let's call it between one and five
million
uh plus those are some endorsements you
don't really know how to track and you
know they they sell some amount of
t-shirts it's hard to know
and then it sort of explodes guys
started signing like you know 10 20
million dollar uh deals but they're
they're they're like multi-year deals
three-year deals or something like that
so you know they're making six million
guaranteed or something like that five
million guaranteed 10 million guaranteed
so
uh that was like the kind of like what
our estimates were for the very very top
guys we thought okay
so how much would we need it's like we
basically did the math and we're like
okay i think you need
i don't remember what the number was
today but let's call it
let's just pretend it was 150 million we
need 150 million dollars to go through
with them but it's like
if i told you you could go raise 150
million and you're saying you needed 150
million dollars in order to pay
the
streamers and tell them bail on twitch
come to our platform and when you come
to our platform you're going to bring
your audience and we're going to make
all this money eventually through other
people coming you get this much
guaranteed all you have to do is just
continue to stream and you have to
promote it in this way and let us
promote you can i make a product we're
going to be 5 million to build this
platform my prediction is that would
never work
i don't think that works okay so tell me
why i'll tell you how it obviously it
didn't happen so you know you're
probably i think it could tell me why
you think well i know that you didn't
really try to do this but uh or i don't
know in earnest i don't know if you
didn't raise 150 million dollars i think
maybe the pga tour could work maybe but
doing this for consumers you need to
have like a brand and you need to have
some magic about it it's kind of like
you know even if you put all of like the
resources into creating a boy band like
sometimes that [__] just don't work even
though like everything like everything
on paper it's like well we got the the
blonde hair kid we got the mixed race
kid we got the uh the dancer we got the
singer like on paper this checks out you
know like this should work you know what
it'd be we should be popular in korea by
this point and it's just there's there's
just no magic right it [__] just happens
and then like you have some like you
know kid who just like sings a funny
song and makes a joke about like wearing
a cowboy hat and he gets hugely famous
like lil nas x or something [__] just
happens and i think that there's like a
bit of magic that probably would be
missing out when you're because with
consumers it's quite challenging to like
grab their attention it's like getting a
cat to play with something it's just
sometimes it works sometimes it doesn't
right so so so i do think that that
that's part of it but there have been
instances where people have thrown money
at the problem and it actually worked
right for every
quibby where you just raise a bunch of
money you go try to do the thing it
doesn't work
for every one of the or every 10 of
those there's one where you're like no
actually they did kind of just brute
force their way in i don't know if you
remember this but
when tick tock first launched
tick tock was lame as hell dude tick
tock was lame as hell it was pigeon
holed as like the lame version of
musically which was a pretty lame thing
it was like 12 year olds lip syncing
videos
and now tick tock is huge and one one
thing that happened in between i
remember
meeting a guy and he was like
yeah you know tick tock is going to
spend a billion dollars marketing the
app because i was like dude there's
billboards in san francisco like at bus
stops to download tick-tock i was like
do they really think this is going to
work
and we had an intern uh not an intern
like a kind of just like a junior guy
working for us he was in ninth grade and
he worked at our company and i was like
he started mentioning tick tock and i
was like is tick tock actually a thing
he's like
yeah you know we just kept hearing about
it kept hearing it kept hearing about
and then they started just paying all of
the top youtubers and vine people to
just make tick tocks
and like it worked you know eventually
it just worked like it's like we all
think it's lame but like we all kind of
started to use it
and then sure enough the lame thing fell
away too by the end of it and it like
you know it became like a pretty
mainstream thing like tick tock really
did brute force their way down they did
a bunch of other things right good
product great algorithm they did a bunch
of other things i'm not saying they
didn't do that but it's not like they
started with this like brand love and
authenticity and like loyalty and things
like that
so let me tell you how this this twitch
thing played out so
i had a hunch that you might be right so
i approached discord
and i said hey discord you want to buy
us and they're like uh
maybe who are you and like what do you
want what do you do i was like oh we do
this thing today but here's what we
would do with discord
we would help you compete with twitch
you have brand love like discord is one
of the most loved brands in gaming it's
like you have the brand you have brand
love
but you don't do this today we will
build the platform and like we can use
this strategy to do this and they were
like well okay this is kind of like a
crazy big pivot idea like respect the
audacity who did you email what role i
don't know
ceo and you said hey ceo i'm sean this
is what i do can i come to your office
and pitch you and then you went to the
office and told him that or you told him
this all exactly
except why did he take your meeting and
he at the end of it at the end of it his
his take was basically like we will
acquire you if you want uh i don't know
if we'll pay the most so you know that's
that's i don't know if the deal will
happen
um and i don't know if we would do this
but the fact that you can come in here
and whiteboard this on a wall makes me
want you to like come here and do things
and like that's
like that's the biggest [__] artist
like i've ever heard of and you almost
pulled it off what was the guy like
he's amazing he's a young guy right he's
like a young nerdy girl jason citron
yeah i was like i never met zuck but i
was like the way he talked about their
product their strategy and like his like
calm like confidence he's like quiet
nerdy confidence i was like
oh i don't want to compete with this guy
and i see why they've kicked everyone's
ass like this is like this guy's really
smart and just really uh like
has a point of view about the way this
needs to go
and
like it's just simple it's
understandable it's different why do you
think he turned through he just feel
like he's gonna actually get on that
um
i think i had gotten a warm intro
through his investor his lead investor i
told his lead investor hey we think
about selling but i went to him and i
was like hey we're thinking about
selling would you do this deal or not
and he was like well you should first
talk to the discord guys and i was like
great you know that's exactly what i was
hoping for
you know because i i just need to create
a bidding war of some kind to get the
you know best deal possible so can you
make that interest so he just emailed
him it was like
um you guys should meet er like you know
here's his email he's like yeah i think
he warm intro you should meet and i just
said hey i'd love to come by the office
today and like
uh you know 40 minutes i'll sketch out
what i have in mind and like you know
you could decide that's so funny nuts or
if uh i'm genius arm nuts and you could
decide for your first but he respected
it i don't know what i said
yeah he was just like you know
would you like to come like
be one of the like c-suite type people
because i don't think we're going to do
that plan that you outlined
but i like you you know like you know
there's not
uh i don't i don't we didn't get that
dude this is how we should be a leader
everyone needs the confidence of a sean
purry this is a great story this is um
proof that you can just create [__] out
of thin air value yeah you can create
value i always say this like
at my last startup the the best thing i
did ultimately in that in that company
was
i did write by the team and the
shareholders of like at the end i put my
best foot forward to try to get us the
most value we could um that was like you
know
of all the things i did that was the
best one and like i tried to do many
other things so i tried to find product
market tried to scale tried to hire a
great team and i did some of those okay
some of those poorly the one thing i did
great was this this process let me let
me finish the story here so then so i'm
like okay these guys don't want to do it
but maybe we could still do it
and so we start trying to set up a
meeting and i realized pretty quickly oh
you have to do this as one
you have to do this as like a coup
because it's kind of like a rebellion
and that i was like we need to do two
things we need to wait till people are
pissed off about something that twitch
does which
big companies will shoot themselves in
the foot they'll come up with policies
they'll they'll make some statement
they'll change some feature they'll
change the revenue split and people get
annoyed i was like so we need to
capitalize on that and then secondly we
need to get everybody all at once you
know that movie that's out there people
like every everything everywhere all at
once
that's i was like that's how we need to
do this we can't just get we can't just
slowly negotiate one by one it won't
feel like there's enough momentum and so
i was like we need to do this at
twitch's big conference where all the
streamers will go to all the big
streamers go because most big streamers
they don't leave their house they're
like they're like me but they actually
have like you know they're actually you
know rich and famous from their
streaming but they can't leave their
room that's like their job and so they
go on vacation very little they take
very few days off the one thing they do
is they often go to twitchcon because
they can meet their fans and it's the
big event
so i was like we need to do like a
dinner the day before the day of or the
day after the conference probably
probably the day before
i was like you know this might be the
worst time because they're going to be
up and you know the twitch kind of like
ecosystem but it's the only time we get
them all in the same room i was like and
we'll lay out our case which is
basically look you guys are going to
make stupid money
if you all are in there's no risk to any
of you individually because you're if
you're all there this will actually work
and see like you don't have to play by
twitch's rules anymore like you have you
know say in this thing
i can't find this client info have you
heard of hubspot hubspot is a crm
platform so it shares its data across
every application every team can stay
aligned no out of sync spreadsheets or
dueling databases hubspot grow better
dude there's this like there's this like
famous meeting that happened in atlantic
city in like 1930s and that's when they
it was all all the mafia guys that got
together and like al capone and all
these guys and that's when they like
formed like the syndicate or whatever
you know like the mob and like you know
it's us versus everyone
that's basically what you did you had
like your little mob meeting and that
sounds awesome
i didn't do it i wanted to do this i
didn't even get there why because there
was one thing that happened and when we
ended up getting acquired by twitch uh
emmett was like hey let's grab a drink
we'll celebrate so we go to the first
time i met him like outside of the
office and we go to this bar and you
know we're talking about stuff and i was
just like you know
uh i was like what do you think's it how
would somebody beat twitch
he's like hmm he's like he's like it's
pretty hard we do have like a pretty
good
business and like you know it's hard to
compete against these like marketplaces
once they get back you know about your
meeting but you know
no no so i go i go i go we had an idea i
don't know if this would have ever
worked we got very close we didn't pull
the trigger ultimately
uh but i always wondered like would this
have worked
and i told him the idea he goes
he goes yeah we've thought about that
like that
i don't want to quote him but like the
the gist of what he said was
if you're gonna do it that's the only
way to do it
but we knew that and that's why we
started signing exclusive contracts with
all these guys and specifically
exclusive contracts that don't line up
so we would make one expire in june and
another expire in january another one
expires and
the following year he's like so that
nobody could ever like they're all off
cycle payment all off cycle contracts so
that nobody could come and like oh
they're all going to be for one of them
all right tiny ass detail
tiny detail right and i was like wow and
then sure enough this actually did end
up somebody did try to do this so
uh microsoft came out this thing called
mixer and they went and they tried to
get the top streamers they gave ninja
like i don't know some stupid 20 30
million dollars to come stream on make
sure he said yes because he's like dude
if i'm making four or five on twitch and
these guys will give me 30 guaranteed um
to go sit here for two years all right
i'll do it and they tell me like this is
integrated with xbox it's gonna like
drive me a bunch of new viewers
cool and then they tried to get shroud
and try to get a bunch of others but
they did it too slowly and so um so this
attack did actually end up happening but
that nobody went out of business didn't
it
yeah because they couldn't get the
critical mass they couldn't get enough
people to say yes
um
but like this did happen like the
chinese streaming platforms tried to do
it like a whole bunch of people tried to
do this against twitch at the same time
and just did a you know a fairly good
job of not only this off cycle
contracting but also figuring out
is crazy there was like this this uh
this like theory which was
how many of your favorite streamers need
to move before you move
and so they looked at like okay if i'm a
viewer if i spend 100 percent of the
time just watching sam and sam leaves
okay i have a high likelihood of leaving
but as long as i can get you to watch
like four people
the odds of all four leaving are very
low and if if one leaves i'm like 95
percent a chance to just stay how about
the fact that they probably hired some
like mit like rocket scientists and he's
like thinking for years like i'm gonna
i'm gonna help get man to mars you know
i'm gonna help i'm gonna be part of
saving the world the human race i'm just
a little small part of this but i'm
helping
and he gets his job offer from spacex
and it's 135 000. and then he gets this
job offer from twitch and it's like 140
000 and he's like
yeah they got free lunch though
uh like you know like it's like the
office is down the street from my house
um i can do it like this this space
thing will always be here you know like
um
their office is beautiful yeah and then
they take that twitch office and then
they spend the next eight years of their
lives and the only point is figuring out
how to make it so a streamer can click a
button and like a cat pops up on their
shoulder like like an emoji you know
what i mean or it's like how do i just
make it so like on monday night football
the first yo the the down line the
yellow line moves perfectly with like
the you know how do i do that you know
space will always be there though but
like how do i get this like first
just imagine someone like dedicating
their lives to that
that that sounds horrible to me
that is um not far from the truth and in
fact some people
try to use that to their advantage um
like you know steve jobs did that thing
where you're saying recruiting john
skilly or whatever he's like you know
when are you gonna stop selling sugar
water to kids and come like help change
the world and uh
uh scott harrison the ceo of charity
water he's like i remember he came to
silicon valley he was recruiting for
charity water and i was like how do you
recruit from like google you this he was
trying to hire somebody from adobe i
remember
he said yeah she makes four times as
much as i'm gonna offer like why would
she take a like a huge pay cut like that
like 4x less he's like
i just got to hope that she wants to do
something that actually matters
i was like well
okay and he actually did succeed in
recruiting a bunch of really interesting
people
um but yeah you know it does happen like
when you're at these companies it's like
what percent of your life
goes towards like being like
you know can we get you know chat
engagement up by 0.2 percent like can we
get the uh you know
if i add this emoji of this like you
know bouncing cat
like are you 34 more likely to come back
next week like you know there's a lot of
life that comes down to you
if you work a big tech company you're
working inside of a slot machine and
you're looking at this like person
sitting down on the stool and you're
like can i get another four quarters out
of them like what do i need
let's hey make that light flash over
there hey hey cherries get a flash yeah
that'll do it my wife you know went to
this fancy ivy league school she's this
brilliant woman and she was at facebook
when we started dating and she was
telling me what she did she's like i'm a
pmm what's at stanford product marketing
manager and i was like what's that mean
she's like oh well we just help people
um like we want more people to use
facebook i'm like oh are you guys like
the thing that puts like the jet above
india so like they get free internet
access she's like oh no not really um
well what do you do she's like well you
know i create um different products to
help people to use facebook like okay
but what do you really do she's like
i'm uh making it so you could put a
sticker on your picture and more people
will spend just a little bit more time
on this app and i'm like oh okay
yeah you should quit right
and like
that's what she quit she's like yeah and
when did something that actually she
cared about but uh yeah i remember
hearing about them like
oh that's why you went into debt for all
these universities and that's why you
did all that we'll see you can
you know walk around the facebook campus
for like three hours a day and make like
a sticker of like poojing the cat or
whatever the [__] that thing was called
remember that thing poojing or
what was that thing it was like it was
like a japanese cat
no idea
it was called like poop remember how uh
facebook they would have all these like
japanese cartoons there was like that
dog with his tongue hanging out i don't
remember it's a thing it was like poo
jean it was like a cat that was asian
and like it was like a series of
stickers that
yeah it's the thing in snapchat that
that dancing hot dog which has been seen
more than like any cartoon or animation
ever uh they've been seen like 10
billion times
100 billion times or something like that
it's like yeah
this hot dog is actually more popular
than mickey mouse just
on that tv show silicon valley one of
the apps that they said was amazing was
nip alert and it alerts you of erect
nipples uh in your vicinity
i'm like ah this sticker thing that's
nipple alert sounds good
yeah honestly when i was there when i
was i didn't think it was like you know
a waste of sort of time and energy in
that sense like
i don't know maybe i think twitch is
actually okay because twitch is like
this is like this cool subculture we're
nerds no one likes us we finally have a
space that we can do this stuff facebook
i think is different
and i respected the game theory of it i
was like when this whole like contract
thing was going down and they were like
you know how basically the question of
how much should we bid i was like i
don't know you know like
it's like in sports there's like this
money ball movement where you're trying
to figure out the value of a player and
if you can accurately
forecast the value of a player you have
an edge in winning in the in the league
the same the same thing is true now for
all these like big media platforms that
are like in which case here they were
bidding for content so they're bidding
for for this and you know i went and met
with people or like you know talk to
people who are at netflix and it's like
hey how do you decide how much to spend
on the production of this or you know
how do you figure out if it was worth it
to spend you know whatever 100 million
dollars on house of cards
and like and you go there and you me you
know you meet the guy who's doing the
same thing right like the brilliant data
scientist
who's like job is to like a b test the
thumbnails of you know like the new
garfield movie to figure out which one
is going to lead to higher engagement
like lower churn and it's like yeah you
know you're you're a b testing
thumbnails for for you for for netflix
and youtube and all this stuff like yeah
that's like
it kind of feels like you know bringing
a gun to a knife fight type of thing
like you're you're you're
damn like really this is where all this
i know but there is it's a scale it's
not binary it's a scale you know and so
for some companies it's like oh no this
is just way too lame for others it's
like oh this got a little pinch of lame
little half a cup of lame but like it's
mostly pretty cool right you know what
i'm saying netflix i actually think
that's cool it's like oh i'm giving the
world a little bit of entertainment
facebook it's like i'm just making
people hate themselves
yeah the thing that i the way i ended up
thinking about it was um
like
do i matter here like uh if i left
like who cares
i call this the django law like if you
remove this block from the jenga tower
tower still there i guess that wasn't a
key block like you know sure we'd love
to have it there it's more it's better
if it's there but like
nah nobody really cares believes like if
i don't really matter here then like
it's very hard for me to get excited
that's kind of an ego thing but it's
also like an impact thing like if i
at a startup like i can i can just by
myself create a product
give value to customers that didn't
exist and i can capture a huge amount of
value and at a big company
i'm neither the key person creating the
value nor the key person nor the person
who captures any of the value right like
your value capture inside of a company
is is is fixed like you you get paid
what you get paid in most cases you know
aside from like maybe a bonus that you
could get um whether your product
succeeds or fails which is why a bunch
of products
fail or go really slow inside these
companies because it doesn't matter you
don't get you don't get a prize if it
works uh you know you get you get praise
and so and and then the other side which
is like you know does this matter and i
think there is a counter argument like i
talked to um let's get josh ellman and
uh and actually even the the chief
product officer at twitch skydan i was
like dan why why do you always join you
know worked at google worked at next
door he worked at now twitch i was like
why are you doing these big companies
like have you ever wanted to go do your
own he's like
yeah but i wanted like impact scale
and i was like i was like oh that's
weird like in my head it was always if
i'm at a small company i have a bigger
impact i am big relative to the company
he's like yeah but that's not how you
think about it like
here if i can improve one product that
10 million people use or at google
a billion people use search uh you know
every single day and so if i can make
that better he's like i created the book
search you know feature i was you know
on the books team we created that
project so now you could like search for
books and like a bunch of people on
earth do that how to start it would be
very hard for me to do that and i was
like
okay like that is the counterpoint is
if you're if you're working at apple and
you're working on the app store like you
know the app store
if a billion people use it every single
day i guess like making that better
reaches a billion people you know making
their life one percent better or
whatever you know that that days is
higher impact than at a startup but it
doesn't feel that way the action doesn't
feel the same to me no i agree you want
to do another topic
can i give you a framework that i think
is uh
pretty dope that i heard
so i was talking to somebody about like
you know um
i guess i can't really say what i was
talking about uh but i was talking about
something it's sort of like you know
let's say the topic of money like
should i do this should i do this it's
going to yield this amount of money or
not and the person was like well the way
i think about money is um
you know because the value of money is
what can you say no to if you have this
money
and i was like what do you mean by that
that's interesting i started he he
actually he didn't even respond but i
was like uh in my head i was like
that's interesting i've never heard that
before and so like i started thinking
about it and i go that's true like
people always say you know i want
financial freedom i want freedom you
know i don't care about money i care
about freedom that's like a common thing
you'll hear
and it's like what does that actually
mean i was like oh it's actually not the
freedom
to do something it's the freedom from
having to do something so it's like what
can i say no to so let me give you kind
of like so i started thinking about my
own life i was like
when i had 25 000 in my bank account i
could say no to a really shitty job like
i didn't have to go flip burgers or be a
janitor because i could i could pay my
like monthly bill
uh and i could do that for like you know
six to 12 months and like cool that
means i didn't have to go get a bad job
a shitty job today but then at like 100k
in the bank you could say no to like a
shitty manager
it's like okay i don't i can't just
retire but i can like quit this job take
a gap and like find another job and i
don't feel like there's like financial
stress in doing that so 100k lets me say
no to a shitty manager i was like half a
million that's what i could say no
to like i don't have to work for a
couple years i could just say no to work
for a little bit temporarily saying six
to 12 months
yeah i could go for a year i could try a
startup or go trap backpacking or
whatever like i could pursue a passion
of some kind
so that's a new thing you could say no
to it's like work for a little while
then it kind of like i would say 3
million you can just say no to jobs like
uh i'm only gonna work for myself i can
bet on myself and and give myself enough
time to figure stuff out without having
to stress about it
at 10 million i think you just say no to
working in general it's like like my
money makes enough money i just don't
need to use my time to make money if i
don't want to
and then it kind of goes on and and
you say no well like i've been thinking
about this as well um at like between
some number maybe around 100 you say no
to
having to be in one location so for
example right now
i rent a place in one location and i own
a place in another location if i had 100
million dollars i'd probably own three
or four homes and it's just like hey
let's just go from place to place to
place i don't have to spend any time
organizing a rental or or anything and
then maybe around like two or three
hundred it's i'm gonna say no to wasting
time at an airport i'm just we only yes
you know we only fly so i think it's
that but the numbers are a little bit
less i said at 50 million i think you
could say no to any inconvenience that
money can solve
you could i think you could but you
could fly private at 50 million you'd
have to own the jet but you could fly
private you sure for sure you could hire
assistants to do anything you need you
can hire you know chefs and drivers and
and you know errands and and accountants
and anything you don't want to do you
don't have to do i talked to you i
talked to 50 million i talked to a guy
there today who owns a jet and
he said it's about two and a half
million a year um in expenses right and
he owns it uh if you want to rent it i
think you could go most you can go to a
lot of places and spend half a million
dollars a year and if you have 50
million that's that's doable but you
can't own like an 8 million house in
brooklyn and then a 3 million dollar
house in austin and then a five million
dollar house in la but you could own
pretty nice [__] in those places
right and so you know like the top
ladders you get 100 million and i think
you could say no to the way the world
world works you get to change some rules
and at a billion i think you say no to
like politicians you say no to the
police you say you say no to a bunch of
people uh when you get to a billion
because
you have the ability to kind of fight
back uh you they
uh they kind of there's there's a
different level of respect so to me i
liked this framework of
what does this amount of money allow me
to say no to that i want to say no to
did you um yeah what would what hourly
rate would you say no to right now for
uh for a project that you don't want to
do for a one-hour phone call what would
you have to accept
uh so like i think they there's like
what you say and then it's like what you
actually like what the market clearing
price actually is so you would you would
right now i charge two thousand dollars
an hour and i take about two hours a
week of phone calls
um would you do that or not
so that's the exact borderline so on glg
that's like what you get the max you can
set my rate to is two thousand
and
if i get a if i get a bid
and i'm like uh this phone call doesn't
sound like it's going to be a lot of fun
um
it's like right at that borderline where
i feel like i kind of should like
for an hour
i i should i don't think i don't take
the calls because i need the money i
take the calls because i feel guilty
saying no
and so it's the same thing right like
feeling like i should means
feeling like i want to say no but i
don't think i should and therefore if i
say no i kind of feel like i made a you
know i'm guilty right like what i've
done well has this i've used the app
intro and i just like for example i'm
flying down to your event and then i'm
flying to la i um i schedule it so i
know when i'm gonna find the money well
i know when i'm gonna be in the uber and
i just make my availability there so i'm
like sick i'll just take this in the
uber and now i can afford like i could
justify a 200 uber black because i'm
making two thousand dollars in this hour
and so i'm gonna be comfortable and i'll
order even early so if i arrive early at
the airport i can just sit outside of
the airport and finish this call so
that's kind of how i've been justifying
it now but right it feels weird selling
time per hour and i don't even know if i
like that in general
yeah exactly so i would say my true
answer is if i don't want to do it right
now i think that the number is something
like two or three thousand dollars for
an hour if i if i just if i don't want
to do it i actually just don't do it but
if it's like borderline if i'm not sure
if i want to do it or i don't think i
would like it but it's not so painful i
think that's my current thing uh but i'm
i'm actively trying to get away from it
like um
something that came up yesterday that
was like this
and i was like
i was by default i was just gonna say
yes and i was like should i say yes to
this let me just like recheck what i
want to be saying yes to
because i think that you know one of the
most important decisions in your life is
what are the things i'm going to say yes
to and what are the things i'm going to
say no to so there's your default box
which is like oh i
i obviously say yes and no to these
things then what are the non-obvious
things so it's like
i want to be saying yes to things that i
know will be fun and help me grow
but scare me a little or put me out of
my comfort zone right so it's like i
know i want to say yes i know i want to
say yes to
if my friend is in town i want to go
pick them up from the airport or if my
mom needs to get to the airport i want
to drive her there like i want to say
yes to tasks that like
um i don't want to do but i actually
want to be the person who does those
things so i'm just like i'm deciding
consciously what are the things that are
like what should i be moving into the
yes box and what should i be moving into
the no box what's some [__] i do today
that i should be saying no do you have a
polite way of saying no to all the
inbound or do you just ignore
i used to just ignore and then i
realized like
it's totally fine to just say
um hey this sounds cool but um i just
got my hands well i don't want to do
anything else or like hey this uh you
know um
hey you know thanks for reaching out um
i don't want to do any more phone calls
that i'm doing right now but if that
changes i'll let you know yeah and like
i'll just say something and i think you
know people hey they just appreciate a
response more than a blow-off
and b
i think there's some level of respect
for um
thoughtfully
yeah
for you know somebody just being honest
and like just saying look
i don't like i don't want to do that um
you know
i i've decided i want to travel less you
know um
so i'm going to say so i'm saying no to
trump dude i had this guy messaging me
saying he wants to come on the pod and i
was just like i ignored it i ignored it
because i hate when people ask to come
on because i'm like dude why are you
gonna make me say no like i say no to
everyone practically even good friends
like we just say no to most everyone and
this guy he was like uh i was hey or he
was like can i come on i'm a huge fan
and i just said like thanks for reaching
out like i didn't even i tried to avoid
it like it was quite obvious and he's
like uh hey so can i come on and i go
you know this isn't a good fit but i
really appreciate you listening and he
was like um
can i get some feedback i was like it's
just not a good fit and he goes okay but
why and i was like
uh okay because you're not interesting
and you're not that successful
and uh
he was angry at me and i was like dude
what what the hell i mean i was trying
to like
you know make a point of like avoiding
this topic and being kind but you if
you're gonna ask for feedback and i'm
gonna tell you you know what what what
it's about don't get angry right
he's like
what's not interesting about it he said
i go
it just there's
you know i just don't care about you
so my my goldilocks thing here was i was
too cold when i just blew people off
because they didn't like that and then
they would just stop like you know
i found i would miss opportunities
because i wouldn't reply to things uh
miss opportunities i cared about uh in
the long run and then the too hot was i
would just be like i don't do phone
calls i was like okay you know you're
sort of a jerk for just being like i
don't do phone calls or like i don't
meet with people i don't know or like
you know i i don't do this it's like too
hard of a rule and i found that the
sweet spot was somewhere in the middle
of just saying
uh you know
hey thanks but uh but you know i'm
trying to do less of this right now or
or sometimes i'll say like
um they'll be like hey did you want to
do this i'd be like
um you know i haven't decided and uh you
know like i don't know i don't even know
what i want yet so let me get clear on
what i want and then i'll come back if i
if i you know when i get clear if i ever
get clear on it but like it's not about
you i just don't know exactly what i
want to do right now
and like i'll just say like something
honest like that and i found that that
that tends to work um a little bit
better dude we went from
hitler to saudi arabia
to saying no to people mental models
yeah mental models
good pod um
you uh
i'm gonna be in la on
sunday you're not coming right
to l.a on sunday no i don't think so but
then i'm gonna see you in what are you
going to what are you going to like i
told you about it i'm hosting an event
there dude for the new york event that
i'm hosting we've got like 1300 rsvps
i'm eager to see how many show up you
got to cut that down right you can't you
can't do it you're going to do a
thousand person event no that's how many
people said they're coming but it's free
so like maybe half will come um but we
put up ten grand you're gonna do a 650
person event
dude it's all guys by the way third
number it's all guys i like scroll
through it's all dudes i could smell
that event already
yeah
it's [__] up man so many chads are
gonna be there and then i'm doing the
same thing in la and that one has like
five or six hundred rsvps um i just uh
you and i were talking about an event
and i was like
kind of like actually this is like a
toilet decision and i just wrote it on
eventbrite on my phone and just posted
it right away and people signed up and i
said we're committed so we're doing that
and then i'm gonna be and then we're
gonna go to uh the carolinas for uh the
thing you're organizing which
everyone's been reaching out to me did
we talk about it last pod
yeah we mentioned that they had the last
spot dude so many people are reaching
out to reach out about they want to come
uh they basically people wanting to come
and i'm like this isn't no no sorry it's
not my thing but so so i came up with a
i was like what do we call this and i
was like i want to call it camp mfm
so it's camp mfm and i was like we could
do these but we could do a bunch of
these we could just do like adult summer
camps basically great ideas what
what is something that's really fun
because i don't want to go to something
that's like like even this like a
thousand person meetup like i'm sure
it's cool in the school well it serves a
different purpose it's a party versus an
experience
yeah so i want to have
experiences you know when you were like
yeah i'm a [__] artist man you know
that's how i have like i don't have
experience this is gonna be a good one
now we gotta come up with another one
let's go to like hope and so some of
these will be like this one which is
like ultra like more like super
exclusive right there's only there was
only supposed to be 12 people going it's
expanded to 24
and um you know that's a lot i i wanted
it to be more like 12
but i'm like there'll be those and i
think we should do some that are for
like
dude if you can like
if you know the phrase you know we don't
do public math manifest cowboys you know
uh sam wants to own a lake like if you
know the inside jokes of this pod
then
you're that's your admittance into the
to this this camp and i was like i think
we should do these like twice a year um
that are just like fun and awesome and
get people together quarterly i mean
camp mfm should be the thing i never
wanted to do the work for this
um and neither do you and so that's like
you know one of the challenges but but
it wasn't a lot of work for this one was
it kind of feel like it is it's a lot
because as soon as i try to do something
i'm like well let's make it [__]
awesome then like you know and so like
all of a sudden like for this basketball
thing we got like nike's giving us all
like like sneakers like from like one of
their players and they were getting like
custom swag we rented these like dope
airbnbs we got like a chef we got like
all this stuff coming together i was
like well if we're gonna have good
people let's get like some like good
names in here let's get like some people
we're excited to meet
and then it's all coming together and
like but like each one of those now i'm
like now i want it to be like awesome if
we're going to do dude we got one like
we you know we get experience we can get
a sponsor to say like all right you get
you get 300 000 a year to do cool [__]
but we get to be there at all the
events yeah okay if somebody wants to do
uh sponsor camp mfm you can do this all
the money will go to basically hiring a
planner to actually like do these things
for us and uh and secondly to uh to you
know the venue and logistics of it all
right that's a part i'm out
[Music]
you